bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france est ce qu'on sera
prêt le 11 mai pour des cons fine
emmanuel macron a affirmé qu'il n'y aura
pas de déconfinement par région hier
alors tout sera prêt le des compliments
ne va pas tout d'un coup je suis vous
voulez donc le contenu de déconfinement
doit être progressif est en fait toute
la difficulté c'est d'affiner la
stratégie de manière
la vague épidémique ne remontent pas
mais ceux des consignes en par région
écarté par emmanuel macron penser que
c'est une décision sage va par exemple
sont des des deux niveaux administratifs
qui correspondent pas à la dynamique de
l'épidémie
si vous voulez donc un par région par
territoire ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
peut des comptines et en fonction de
comment la vague épidémique a frappé les
différents territoires en 30 et on ne
fera pas le même piste de déconfinement
dans une région qui a été déjà
relativement tranchées ou et militer et
une région qui a été très peu touchée où
on pense à plus de personnes juchées le
début il ya un rapport de l'institut
pasteur publié le 21 avril dernier
qu'alerte sur le risque d'une deuxième
vague de l'épidémie s'il est toutes les
mesures de contrôle sont son lever 11
mai
que faut-il penser de ce rapport alors
il est pratiquement certain qu'on aura
une deuxième vague épidémique
si vous voulez contenu de la
transmissibilité du corps navires us
deux corps en a dit rush il faut
atteindre 70% de la population ayant
développé des anticorps ayant été une
idée avant de pouvoir complètement
arrêter la transmission est aujourd'hui
on est à 1 - 2 % de la population à la
mi mai on sera peut-être un peu au
dessus mais on sera loin des 70
construction nécessaires à éviter une
seconde vague
donc c'est parfait qu'il doit maintenir
un certain niveau de mesures afin de ne
pas laisser la libre champ à une
deuxième pas d'épidémie vous vivez vous
même en suède puisqu'on parle de sa
stratégie concernant l'immunité
collective
c'est un pays qui a choisi de
privilégier des simples recommandations
à sa population par rapport à des
mesures contraignantes
quels regards vont porter sur cette
stratégie à mener justement en suède
alors dans le contexte de suez doivent
cibler le conseil le simple conseil
plutôt que l'obligation de buzz
compliqué c'est l'arrière suédois lampe
est belle de faire des recommandations
donc en fait à stockhom vous pouvez voir
très clairement que les gens se confine
il ya beaucoup moins de temps dans les
ruines les restantes sont vides
donc il ya des mesures sur l'aide à la
grèce n'a pas décidé de laisser le virus
se répandre simplement il n'y a pas de
mesures coercitives et sur le virus lui
même puisqu'on voit quand il ya quand
même des disparités en europe et des
pays qui sont beaucoup plus touchées la
france
on a vu ce qui s'est passé en italie
c'est encore le cas en espagne au
royaume uni et puis on a des pays comme
l'allemagne la suède où finalement
l'épidémie on a l'impression qu'elle
n'est pas aussi forte
alors je peux vous parler de la fed
en fait en fait comme vous rapportez
l'épidémie à la population suédoise
c'est pratiquement un niveau similaire
avec ce qui se passe en france le nombre
de morts rapporté à la population du
même en suède et enfants et d'un nombre
de cas et supérieurs en fait en suède
que qu'en france quand on rapporte à la
population parce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est on ne jure pas le nombre de cas et
le nombre des décès de la même manière
dans tous les pays
et ça ça rend les comparaisons
excessivement difficile c'est à dire en
allemagne par exemple on fait beaucoup
plus de tests 500 milles par semaine
donc on détecte beaucoup plus de cas
qu'ils font des formes ou
asymptomatiques très peu symptomatiques
qui ne sont pas forcément détecté en
france et qui font pas détecté
actuellement suède
donc le nombre de cas n'est pas un bon
indicateur en fait de la dynamique de
l'épidémie dans un pays ça veut dire que
les tests c'était quand même un
impératif au début de même de l'épidémie
lorsque leia 2 il ya deux approches pour
pauvres le contrôle de cette épidémie il
ya ce qu'on appelle le continent en
anglais je suis pas comment lieu en
france et certaines notes entraînements
et après la liturgie donc d'abord on
essaie de bloquer l'épidémie pourquoi
contester tous les gens qui sont en
contact avec des cas pour les isoler
pour éviter la contagion
quand l'épidémie démarrons peu plus tard
à yakro de vente ils sont soit 1,1 à ce
moment là on est des mesures de sanction
sociale de protection du leader quand la
vague est passée dont deux quarts du
temps alors il faut remettre en place
cette stratégie de tests autour des cas
pour du son et éviter que que ces cas
asymptomatiques dans la population ne
régénère une juste une toute dernière
question rapidement le masque il est
impératif alors le masque
il est très conseillé et probablement
impératif dans les transports en commun
bondés qui vont promener dans un parc au
moment où les par gorée ouvriront sur
une plage qui n'est pas bondée je pense
que masque n'est pas dupe il
merci beaucoup à vous donner colombier
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt franc je rappelle que vous êtes
épidémiologistes chef de l'unité
préparation et réponse aux épidémies au
centre européen de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies siens